globally we are much better off than we
used to be of course
in uh well uh well advanced countries
rich countries people are much richer
but the world as a whole is getting
richer which is why
poverty has declined absolute poverty
has declined for about 90 percent of
humanity in 1800
to less than 8 today i just want to
repeat that
in 1800 just 200 years ago 90
of people lived on two dollars per
person per day
today roughly eight percent of people
live on two dollars per person per day
so um yes the the great
increase in in riches has resulted in a
substantial reduction
in uh in absolute poverty we have seen a
billion people
rise from absolute poverty in china in
the last 40 or 50 years
we are seeing india coming up we are
seeing a number of african countries
growing at five percent per year
um there is a lot of good news that's
happening in the world
i want to go into the the top 10 that
you talk about here but the book has
78 trends that are going well so we're
going to plow through the top 10 and
then i'm just going to
i'm going to quiz you on a couple of
random ones as well but i'm going to go
through them right here so
the first trend that you guys have is
the great enrichment
and this is basically about the economy
so can you lay this out because a lot of
people think we're we're poor
the divide is worse than ever and we
seem to be getting poorer
but it's actually not true
since the historical record begun um
people lived on about two dollars per
person per day
2000 years ago at the time of christ or
caesar augustus
people in america in europe in africa
anywhere in the world lived on two
dollars a day or so
that is why today when we talk about
absolute poverty
about living at a subsistence level we
talk about that
two dollar level because that's how
people used to live
since the dawn of time really um
now bringing it back to or bringing it
forward all the way to 1800s at the time
of thomas jefferson presidency
global income per capita per day is only
2.80
so it's still very very low but today
200 years later
it is 44 dollars per person per day
globally
in the united states is roughly 160
dollars per person per day
and if if the current trends continue
if we are able to repeat the growth that
we had over the last 100 years
and project it to 2100
then average global income will be 144
dollars per person per day
so from two dollars since the dawn of
time
to 44 today to about 150
in 2100 that's the extent of the
tremendous economic growth that we have
experienced in the last 200 years
and that we can still experience in the
future so i think one of the things that
confuses people
at least when we hear this through the
mainstream media is there the i
there's this idea that the rich keep
getting richer and that the poor are
getting poorer
but but the argument that you're laying
out in essence is not that the rich
aren't getting richer many rich people
are getting richer
but that the entire pool is actually
being raised at the same time so that
the
the lowest person is in far better shape
now than they were say
200 years ago that's correct uh the data
which i just presented
are data based on global average which
is to say
a person living maybe somewhere in
indonesia or malaysia
right in the middle of the pack they the
the data is not distorted
uh by uh by you know looking at just
very rich people
and high income inequality or what have
you globally
we are much better off than we used to
be of course in uh
well uh well advanced countries rich
countries people are much richer
but the world as a whole is getting
richer which is why poverty has declined
absolute poverty has declined from about
90 percent of humanity in 1800
to less than eight percent today i just
want to repeat that
in 1800 just 200 years ago 90
of people lived on two dollars per
person per day
today roughly eight percent of people
live on two dollars per person per day
so um yes the the great
increase in in riches has resulted in a
substantial reduction
in in absolute poverty we have seen a
billion people
rise from absolute poverty in china in
the last 40 or 50 years
we are seeing india coming up we are
seeing a number of african countries
growing at five percent per year
um there there's a lot of good news
that's happening in the world or at
least there was before covet
and since uh this election is a week
away we should talk about the the forces
that
make all of that happen it has a little
something to do with free markets right
that's correct the greatest decline in
absolute poverty in the world
is uh co-terminus with
the opening of the global economy after
1980. this is called the period of
globalization
now i realized that a lot of people
including a lot of people in the united
states are
ambivalent about globalization but there
is no doubt
that once these formerly poor countries
dropped socialism and central planning
embraced free markets
embraced multinational corporations and
inward foreign investment
once that happened these countries
started to grow at a much faster pace
which is why today
places like china are middle income
countries
they are no longer dirt poor i mean at
the time of mao
these people literally ate dirt today
they are sending people to the moon
well at least to space so like working
on that
the last the last 40 years have been
exceptionally good
especially for poor countries yeah all
right
let's go to number two here which is
really an offshoot of this that that in
many ways
we're at the end of poverty
absolute poverty yes as you well know in
the united states
we no longer have absolute poverty
nobody lives on two dollars per day
even people who don't have a job can
access
food and all sorts of facilities which
are provided by the taxpayer
but globally absolute poverty
had been or was before covet at its
lowest it has ever been which is to say
less than eight percent and now of
course as
countries become richer they start to
redefine poverty in a different way
which is why in the united states we
don't talk about absolute poverty when
we talk about poverty it's a relative
poverty it's a certain percentage of the
mean national income
that we consider if people live under
that they are in poverty but but we
don't have absolute poverty in the
united states
so you know from someone sitting where i
am in los angeles
we're i'm seeing many more homeless
people than there were
a couple years ago we know this is
happening in a lot of the big cities in
portland and seattle certainly in san
francisco
i think people see that you know you see
tent cities you see more homeless people
et cetera et cetera and and the
inclination is oh well i'm seeing
something so it must be
it must be significantly worse than it
was
um but is it is it just that that's
happening in just
some cities or or is it just that your
anecdotal evidence doesn't really
prove anything well whether you look at
poverty as a as a relative measure
relative poverty as a percentage of
national income or whether you look at
consumption poverty in other words how
much do people actually spend
on on monthly basis or weekly basis
poverty is an all-time low
i suspect that what's happening in
places like san francisco and los
angeles
is that new policies have been
implemented by local governments
which make it more attractive for uh
for for people who uh may
not be necessarily interested in in in
jobs may not necessarily be interested
in normal uh
lifestyles people who may for whatever
reason prefer
the um the the the freedom
essentially of not being tied to any any
uh anything concrete and want to live in
these ten cities
and who may have been living in those
ten cities throughout the united states
but
for whatever reason because the policies
of local governments have now changed
these people are being pulled like a
magnet towards certain jurisdictions and
that's why you see many more of them
that would be
uh i i think one reason uh why why you
see it anecdotally
yeah and we do know by the way that
they're they're putting in policies in
places like san francisco and los
angeles that are
attracting more homeless people it's not
something that you're just making up at
one point there was a policy i'm not
sure if we still have it in los angeles
where if you build a structure on public
land
they they can't remove it you got an
awful lot of people paying
paying mortgages on land that they
bought i don't know what we're doing
over here
i would simply add just to clarify one
comment i made in my last uh um
contribution and that is that uh when i
say that people don't necessarily want
to
have a home and work for living etc
it i'm not making a value judgment i'm
saying that there is a there are a lot
of people who have very different
conceptions about what a good life
is and also in addition to that there
are a lot of people who
may be mentally unstable uh who have all
sorts of mental
uh problems that prevents them from
keeping a job
and remaining in one place um at the
same time
right so and naturally you're saying
there there are things potentially that
government
or private citizens can do for those
people
but that overall this this is working
and getting well well there are two
sides of that ledger on the one hand you
want to do something for people
uh who are at the very bottom of society
on the other hand
uh that shouldn't mean that you make
life unlivable
uh for people who live in these cities
and who actually pay taxes
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversation about the
environment instead of non-stop yelling
check out our environment playlist and
if you want to watch
full interviews on a variety of topics
check out our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell